moi je dis quand on coupe le clitoris
des petites filles au nom du respect
culturel je dis non
toi aussi tu as un intello très
médiatique
ouais je sais pas ce que ça veut dire tu
sais très médiatique ça veut dire
par semaine sur France 3 tout à fait qui
s'appelle français si vous parlez exact
et tu vas en province mais je fais plus
parler des autres que je parle moi-même
tu donnes la parole récepteur plutôt que
émetteurs c'est ça exactement je fais
parler les gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude
de la parole et j'aime bien en fait
qu'on change un peu que ce soit pas
toujours les mêmes qui parlent sans
démagogie du tout je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont des choses à
dire au moins aussi intéressantes que
les gens qui sont les professionnels de
la parole ce sont les gens qui parlent
c'est-à-dire que en général ça va vous
frapper c'est que quand tu vois dans les
journaux tu vois le représentant machin
leader syndicale le représentant de X et
alors les infirmières les routiers les
agriculteurs tu les vois jamais on les
voit en train de flamber des de la
viande en train de [__] les camions tu
vois en embouteillage et en fait tu as
30 secondes et après sa vie ce type ses
problèmes tout ça rien ben moi j'ai
envie qu'il parle un peu plus c'est pour
ça que tu fais quoi les cahiers de
doléances finalement
c'est ça le tiers état quand tu publies
chez Albin Michel un bouquin qui
s'appelle l'être ouverte à ceux qui ne
sont rien et qui veulent être tout ça
aussi c'est très proche de du cahier de
l'air ça c'est la même épice c'est oui
tout à fait c'est Apple prolongement
mais en réflexion le livret qui permet
la réflexion parce que ne permet pas
l'image en fin de la même façon en gros
c'est quoi c'est que j'ai dit que il y a
une implosion c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
plus les chefs ne sont plus suivis on
l'a bien vu avec l'histoire de
Maastricht que ce soit des chefs
syndicaux politiques religieux ou autre
même médiatique même médiatique et ce
qui est intéressant c'est où on va et ce
que je dis c'est que si on commence pas
à considérer que les gens ce qui compte
c'est la liberté ce qui compte c'est de
ne pas se laisser enfermer dans des
étiquettes ethniques nationalistes
raciale ou autre mais foutu c'est Bosnie
Sarajevo partout et c'est ça qu'il faut
arrêter et la Bosnie c'est rien vous
elle est pas seulement dehors quand on
dit qu'il faut aider les autres c'est
vrai mais aussi dans nos têtes faut
faire très très gaffe à ça côté
attention lui il est comme ça l'autre
est comme ça ça c'est insupportable et
c'est ça qu'il faut casser en tout cas
essayer c'est très écologiste aussi non
c'est pas écologiste c'est que ce que je
dis en gros c'est que ce qu'on a appelé
le communisme et qui n'a jamais été
autre chose qu'un capitalisme d'État
s'est cassé la gueule et c'est bien le
capitalisme archaïque du laisser faire
et laisser aller on voit très bien le
résultat que ça donne et peut-être que
le capitalisme corrigé par l'écologie
tout comprendre il y a une chose c'est
que quand on dit il faut aider tant que
les gens ont dit moi j'ai mon truc les
autres je m'en fous en fait c'est pas la
morale qui va faire mais le jour où tu
as une couche de jaune qui craque et que
c'est bon pour les riches pour les peaux
pour les gauche pour la droite quand il
y a les Tchernobyl qui risque de craquer
quand tu as des du nucléaire qui sort et
ben nucléaire il va me faire attention
entre les lentilles et je pense que plus
ça sera pire mieux ça sera donc non je
pense qu'il faudra faire de plus en plus
attention parce que il y a une globalité
tu penses que le capitalisme écologique
c'est le poste socialiste je pense en
tout cas que l'écho capitalisme est
quelque chose qui remplacera le
socialisme qui d'ailleurs qu'on a jamais
vu il prend son virage le pervers pas du
tout j'ai jamais été socialiste au sens
marxien du terme je dis simplement qu'il
faut arrêter de penser que les solutions
viennent toutes d'en haut les pages 54
tu dis en fait
service vaut 10 philosophes parce que je
pense que quelquefois la consommation
qu'on a beaucoup tu sais qu'on a
beaucoup à attaqué la marchandise en
disant
ouais les situationsnistes c'était très
important cela dit la marchandise tu
crois que l'esclavage était aboli
pourquoi par souci humanitaire par dire
là là on peut plus des esclaves pas du
tout parce que les esclaves pouvaient
devenir des consommateurs car Ford a
décidé de bien payer les ouvriers parce
qu'ils ont des ouvriers il faut qu'on
les paye bien parce qu'ils vont acheter
nos produits faut comprendre ça et ça
n'a rien à voir avec la morale et ben
c'est pas mal je préfère que le mec soit
consommateur qu'esclave tu dis qu'il
faut plus comprendre dans la morale de
gauche
l'indulgence pour les pédophiles les
assassins d'enfants etc non je dis
simplement que au nom de la différence
il faut pas accepter n'importe quoi je
veux dire qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
prôné le respect des cultures moi je dis
quand on coupe le clitoris des petites
filles au nom du respect culturel je dis
non quand on fait tout ce qui est mutile
tout ce qui auprès aux primes au nom du
respect culturel je dis non et je dis
simplement que effectivement un
pédophile un mec qui manipule les petits
garçons ou les petites filles pour moi
c'est de la merde et que ça doit être
condamné quel que soit la chose il y a
une morale mais la morale c'est pas une
morale judo-chrétienne c'est simplement
des règles que des gens se sont battus
pendant des siècles pour établir et
qu'il y a pas à avoir honte de ses
règles et à pas à les renier c'est tout
voilà
mais il faut les enfoncer les portes
ouvertes parce que souvent pour beaucoup
de gens ils sont encore fermés
parce que tu dis que dans le sexe on est
rentré en faisant un autre bouquin qui
est sorti il y a pas longtemps ouais on
est rentré dans le règne de l'ersatz
avec le Minitel avec le cinéma le film
porno
il y a il faut dire là dans dans social
histoire du parti en jouet mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a comme tu sors un bouquin
tous les deux mois quand on t'invite on
en profite pour parler de tout ce que je
voulais dire c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a une normalisation de la
société non plus au nom de la religion
parce que ça marche plus mais au nom de
l'hygiène avec écoute qu'est-ce qu'on
dit on dit ne sortez pas il y a des
loupes dehors qui vont attaquer ne
mangez pas il y a de la pollution ne
baisez pas il y a le sida le fumez pas
c'est les poumons voilà
ne buvez pas c'est l'alcool alors
résultat des courses on a l'impression
que l'idéal d'un certain nombre de gens
c'est quoi c'est voilà ce type c'est la
société tu vois on s'enferme on a test
d'antithèse prothèse alors on a son fax
on a sa machine à communiquer on a son
téléphone et puis on est content donc on
est plus dans les solitaires plus on est
entouré de machines à communiquer il
communique rien du tout
ah c'est complètement c'est le nouvel
ordre moral au nom de l'hygiène tu crois
qu'il vaut mieux danser sur un champ de
mine toi complètement ouais comme lui
par exemple
[Applaudissements]
ce que je vais lire c'est que il faut
être informé quand nous informe mais à
partir du moment où on est adulte qu'on
nous [__] la paix tu sais ce que c'est
c'est qu'en fait on veut on fait une
société sous préservatif toute la
société pas seulement le sexe la société
préservatif attention ne prenez plus
aucun risque et le problème c'est qu'on
a des écrivains sans risque on a des des
chercheurs sans risque on a des des
intellectuels sans risque c'est ça qui
t'emmerde et c'est ça dans ton souffre
ce que dit on a des livres sans risque
on a les livres sans risque absolument
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu